สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่น
กันค่ะขอต้อนรับนะคะนักเรียนทุกคนสู่ห้อง
เรียน comprehensive ไทยห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ค่ะใช่แล้วนะคะวันนี้ครูบีกับครูชิก็มาพบ
กันอีกแล้วนะคะวันนี้เรามาพบกันในวันอะไร
คะครูชิวันนี้เรามาพบกันในวันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 6 ค่ะเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะอืมเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหรู่ชิเดือน
ที่ 2 ค่ะเดือนที่ 2 ปีพ.ศรอคะ
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศเหรอคะค.ศหรือคริสตศักราช 2
24 ค่ะนะคะเราก็มาเจอกันวันอังคารที่ 6
นะคะกุมภาพันธ์นะคะพุทธศักราช
2567 หรือคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะครูบีนะเราบอกแล้วว่าเดี๋ยวเรา
จะมาเจอกันอีกอ้อแล้ววันเนี้ยมาเจอกัน
เนี่ยครูชิมีเรื่องอะไรคะจะมาคุยกับครูบี
หรือจะพาครูบีเเนี่ยไปเที่ยวไหนหรือเปล่า
เฮ้ยครูบีทำไมรู้ล่ะครูชิกำลังจะชวนครู
บีเเนี่ยไปเที่ยวเรือสำราญค่ะ
ว้าวเหมือนไททานิคอย่างงั้นหรอคะใช่เรือ
สำราญนี่ต้องเป็นเรือใหญ่ค่ะเหมือนๆเอา
โรงแรมค่ะมีห้องนอนมีห้องบาร์มีคอกเทล
เล้ามีคอฟี่ shop มีบริการเยอะแยะให้เรา
ค่ะเราไปอยู่บนเรือเนี้ยเราจะต้องสำราญ
สำราญคือสนุกมีความสุขสบายโอทุกอย่างเลย
อ่ะแต่ขอถามหน่อยค่ะเรือสำราญเนี่ยมี
คาราโอเกะมั้ยมีลลลลลลลลชอบ
คาราโอเกะมีคาลาโอเกะมีโกเทคมี
โอทุกอย่าง
อ่าเข้าใจแล้วว่าทำไมเขาถึงเรียกว่าเรือ
สำราญ
ออไปแล้วเราต้องมีความสุขแน่นอนใช่มั้ยคะ
ครูบีอยากไปจังเลยอ่ะครูชิแต่ว่าเรือ
สำราญเนี่ยแปลว่าเราเนี่ยต้องนั่งเรือ
แล้วก็ไปเที่ยวนอนอยู่ในเรือกินอยู่ใน
เรือหรอคะใช่ค่ะครูบีแล้วก็เรือสำราญนะ
เดือนเนี้ยกุมภาพันธ์เนี้ยจะมีเรือสำราญ
จากประเทศต่างๆค่ะหลายๆประเทศเนี่ยมา
ประเทศไทยค่ะเอ้าทำไมคะทำไมต้องเป็นเดือน
นี้เดือนกุมภาพันธ์วาเลนไทน์เหรอคะคือจะ
มีบริษัทที่จัดการท่องเที่ยวทางเรือนะคะ
แล้วก็จับมือกับเรือสำราญของอังกฤษเรือ
สำราญของสวีเดนเรือสำราญของประเทศหลายๆ
หลายๆที่ก็จะมีช่วงเวลาที่เรือสำราญเนี่ย
บางบางลำเนี่ยก็ไปยุโรปอบางลำก็มาเอเชีย
นะฮะไปประเทศต่างๆก็มีบางช่วงที่คนซื้อ
ท่องเที่ยวเนี่ยจาก
ประเทศยุโรปแล้วก็มาลงประเทศไทยมาลงลง
เรือที่นี่แล้วก็มีคนจากกรุงเทพฯค่ะอื
ขึ้นเรือไปเที่ยวอืมอาจจะไปยุโรปหรือไป
สิงคโปร์ไปปีนังแล้วแต่โปรแกรมอค่ะอันนี้
ก็แปลว่าอย่างนึงเลยเดือนนี้เนี่ยเขาบอก
ว่าเป็นเดือนแห่งความรักด้วยไงอ่า
วาเลนไทน์ใช่มั้ยเดือนกุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยวัน
ที่ 14 กุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยเป็นวาเลนไทน์นะ
แล้วก็เดือนกุมภาพันธ์ก็เป็นเดือนแห่ง
ความรักอาจจะมีหลายคนอยากไปท่องเที่ยว
เรือสำราญก็ได้ค่ะไปผู้ชายผู้หญิงใช่มั้
แล้วก็ก็ไปฮันนีมูนหรือว่าไปเที่ยวเป็น
แฟนกันเอ้ออพูดแล้วก็อยากไปอยากไปเอาแบบู
จะแนะนำที่ไหนก่อนคะไปเที่ยวประเทศอะไรดี
คืออย่าง
งี้ช่วงเดือนเนี้ยช่วงเดือนเนี้ยนะก็จะมี
เอ่อการเที่ยวเรือสำราญเนี่ยที่คนไทย
เนี่ยสามารถที่จะไปไปร่วมการเดินทางได้
อืมนะคะเป็นบบริษัทที่เกี่ยวกับการท่อง
เที่ยวเรือโดยเฉพาะเลยแล้วก็มีประสบการณ์
ในการจัดเที่ยวทางเรือค่ะอืนะคะแล้ว
บริษัทนี้นะคะทำเอ่อเกี่ยวกับเรื่องการ
ท่องเที่ยวเรือสำราญเนี่ยในเส้นทางทั่ว
โลกอ่ะหแล้วก็ทำมานานเป็น 10 กว่าปีค่ะ
ครูบีนะอเป็นบริษัทที่ทำเกี่ยวกับเป็น
ทัวร์ทางเรือใช่มั้ยเรือสำราญเรือใหญ่ๆ
ใช่
เออทีนี้ถ้าถามว่าในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีเรือ
สำราญของประเทศไทยมั้ยโอเมื่อก่อนค่ะอื
เมื่อก่อนมีเรือท่องเที่ยวเอ่อเรือสำราญ
ในประเทศไทย 2 บริษัทอืนะแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
ปิดทำการไปหมดแล้วเป็นเรือขนาดที่ไม่ใหญ่
ค่ะเป็นเรือเรือแบบ 7 ชั้นนะคะเป็นเรือ
ที่จุคนไปเที่ยวเนี่ยประมาณสัก 200  300
คน
อืมอันนี้คือไม่ได้ใหญ่มากอืใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
พาคนไทยอ่ะเที่ยวเกาะในประเทศไทย
อืราคาก็ไม่แพงค่ะนะเมื่อก่อนนะก็มีเรือ
เอ่อสำราญ 2 ลำนะคะเป็น
เรือเอ่อซีทาควีนนะคะแล้วก็มีเรือ
อันดามัน Princess มี 2 บริษัทปัจจุบัน
เนี้ยปิดแล้วหลังจากเจอโควิดปิดเนาก็อาจ
จะตั้งแต่มีไวรัสโควิดก็ไม่มีนักท่อง
เที่ยวนะบริษัทเรือสำราญเนี่ยก็เลยปิดไป
แล้วเอ้าแล้ววันนี้ครูชิจะมาแนะนำเรือ
สำราญของที่ไหนล่ะคะจะไปเที่ยวไหนอ่ะ
อันเนี้ยเป็นเรือสำราญจากต่างประเทศค่ะ
ที่เดือนเจะมีเข้ามาเนี่ยประมาณ 6 ลำเป็น
เรือขนาดใหญ่ใหญ่กว่าเรือสำราญที่เคยวิ่ง
ในประเทศไทยและแน่นอนท่าเรือต้องเป็นท่า
เรือที่สามารถเรือใหญ่ๆเนี่ยเข้ามาจอดได้
อเป็นท่าเรือแหลมฉบังอ๋อคือเรือเนี่ยมัน
ใหญ่มากเวลาเรือจะมาจอดเนี่ยต้องเป็นท่า
เรือที่ใหญ่ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ท่าเรือแหมชะบัง
เหรอคะครูชิใช่ค่ะเขาบอกว่าท่าเรือเนี่ย
ต้องมีน้ำลึกค่ะท่าเรือน้ำลึกที่เรือ
เอ่อเรือที่กินน้ำลึกเนี่ยประมาณ 9 เมตอื
มตต้องจอดที่นี่ค่ะแต่ถ้าจะเข้าไปในอะไร
อ่ะเอ่อเจ้าพยาใช่มั้ยอาจจะต้อง 7 มตแบบ
เนี้ย
อืมแต่เรือท่องเที่ยวบางลำเนี่ยกินน้ำลึก
เท่าไหร่ 14 เมตอ่ะครูบีโอใหญ่ไงเรือสูง
ข้างล่างก็ต้องลึกลงไปแล้วก็แบบไม่งั้น
เนี่ยมันมันถ่วงดุลไม่ได้ไงอืมถูกมยใช่ก็
ต้องดูด้วยว่าเรือเนี่ยจะไปจอดที่ท่าเรือ
ไหนได้เนาะอืใช่ค่ะนะคะแล้วก็เรือท่อง
เที่ยวเนี่ยบางลำที่เข้ามาในช่วงเดือน
เนี้ยที่จะมาเนี่ยก็เป็นเรือที่เอ่อระดับ
กลางๆนะไม่ได้แบบใหญ่มากนะคะูชี้ให้ดู
เรือก่อนที่จะเข้ามาในประเทศไทยอันนี้ก็
เป็น 1 ลำที่จะมานะคะคนไทยสามารถไปเที่ยว
ได้อันนี้ก็อีก 1 ลำและนี่คือถ่าเรือแหลม
ฉะบังเห็นมั้ยคะจะมีเรือเรือสำราญเนี่ย
จอดอยู่ 2 ลำณิวจะเห็นเนี่ยโกูชิอันนี้
คือแค่อันนี้คือขนาดกลางๆเหรอค่ะใช่ค่ะ
สำหรับครูบีเเนี่ยใหญ่
มากกูถ้าเทียบกับรถหรือตู้คอนเทนเนอร์
เห็นมยเรือเนี่ยโอ้โหใหญ่จริงๆค่ะอืนะอัน
นี้เราถือว่าขนาดกลางเพราะบางทีมันมีแค่
11 ชั้นนะคะถ้าเรือลำที่ใหญ่มากๆเนี่ย
อาจจะอย่างงี้ค่ะอเรือแบบโอชนิดที่แบบ 20
ชั้น 21 ชั้นได้มั้งเนี่ยนะคะแล้วก็มีที่
ที่ไปเที่ยวอ่ะอนี่คอ๋ออันนี้คือเป็นทริป
ใช่มยคะูชิใช่ค่ะอันเนี้ยอันเนี้ยเป็นปี
24 อันนี้มันผ่านไปแล้วค่ะใช่มั้ยเอ้ยปี
นี้ปีนี้แต่มันเป็นยังไม่ถึงอ่ะอเบอร์
เนี่ยมันแบบมันยังยังไม่มานะแต่แต่คนจะ
ซื้อทัวร์เรือลำเนี้ยเขาก็จะขายล่วงหน้า 1
ปีนะถ้าใครอยากวางแผนจะไปราคาค่ะอื
11,900 อือันนี้เริ่มต้นจากเอ่อห้องที่
ไม่มีหน้าต่างนะคะห้องที่ไม่มีหน้าต่าง
คือห้องที่อยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะที่เห็นกลมมเล็กๆ
เล็กๆเนี่ยอยู่ตรงเนี้ราคา 200,000 กว่า
บาทแต่ 11 วันอืมนะ 11 วัน 8 คืนน่าจะมี
การไปไปพักบนฝั่งด้วยนะคะอืเพราะว่าอยู่
บนเรือ 8 คืนใช่มั้ยค่ะแล้วก็มีห้องพัก
ชั้นต่างๆเหมือนเหมือนเรายกโรงแรมไปด้วย
อ่ะครูบีอื
โอโหใช่เลยกูชิเพราะว่าอันนี้ช่วงเดือน
ตุลาคมใช่มั้ยคะใชค่ะตุลาคนะคะเอามาแบบ
ว่าใกล้ๆบ้านเราหน่อยราคาไม่ค่อยแพงอืนะ
คะอันนี้เนี่ยเป็นทริปที่ไปสิงคโปร์
มาเลเซีย 3 วัน 2 คืนอื 3 วันแล้วก็ 2
คืนที่นอนนะคะก็ราคา
1,999 บาทโอหไม่แพงค่ะ
1,999 บาทไม่แพงถ้า 20,000 บาทเนี่ย
แพงถ้า 19,000 ก็แพงใช่
มั้ยเอันอันนี้คือแพ็คเกจใช่มั้ยถ้าเราจะ
ซื้อใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะครูบีครูบีจะให้ครูชิ
ดูเนาะค่ะอ่าในแพ็คเกจเนี่ยเมื่อกี้ไงครู
ชิแชร์ไว้ก่อน
สิครูชินึกว่าครูบีจะโชว์อะไรนะคะอ่าอัน
นี้คือ
1,999 บาทเนี่ยไม่แพงแต่ถ้า 20,000 บาท
เนี่ยแพงค่ะูชิ
เออนะเออคนไทยชอบอันนี้คนไทยชอบค่ะอืบวก
อีก 1,000 กับ 1 บาทเนี่ย 20,000 เนี่ย
แพง
อื
1,999 บาทไม่แพงนะแล้วก็หูเท่าที่ดูใน
รูปเนี่ยไอ้นี้คือเคให้ดูข้างในเรือหรอคะ
มีสระว่ายน้ำด้วยใช่ค่ะแน่นอนเรือสำราญ
ต้องมีอะไรที่เกี่ยวกับความสุขเดี๋ยวเรา
ดูทริปการเดินทางก่อนนะได้หรืออันนี้ค่ะ
นะคะอันนี้ก็เอ่อน่าจะวิ่งในเอเชียเหมือน
กัน 14,
999 บาทครูบิวทำไมต้องมี 9 ก็บอกแล้วนะ
ถ้ามี 999 เนี่ยก็จะรู้สึกว่าราคาไม่แพง
เนาะอ่าถ้าในแเอเชียใช่มั้ยูชิอันอืเออัน
นี้ทิสิงคโปร์กัวลาลัมเปอร์ปีนัง 4 วัน 3
คืนอโอไม่แพงค่ะ 4 วัน 3 คืนแล้วก็เดือน
เยแหละเดือนกุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยแหละเห็นมั้ย
วันที่
25-28 เรือจะมาแล้วนะ
โอ้โหซื้อตอนนี้รอวันที่ 25 ไปเที่ยวเลย
ครูบี
อออันนี้น่าสนใจมากค่ะภูชิโหโปรแกรมแต่ละ
อย่างเนี่ยตอนนี้น่าสนใจมากนะคะอืมเพราะ
ว่าจะมีเรือเข้ามาหลายลำไงเค้าก็เลยต้อง
ขายไว้ก่อนนะเริ่มขายนี้ก็มีราคา
2,999 บาทเย้ราคาไม่แพงนะคะก็สิงคโปร์
กัวลาลัมเปอร์มาเลเซียเนาะอ่าใช่นะคะ 3
วัน 2 คืนอืมคก็มีทริปไปสิงคโปร์นะมีทริป
ที่ไปยุโรปนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นทัวร์ของ
เรือสำราญทีนี้เรามาดูค่ะว่าเรือสำราญที่
เราเห็นเนี่ยอืมีอะไรให้เราสำราญบ้าง
อ้า
เรานั่งเรือสำราญแล้วเราจะไปทำอะไรที่ทำ
ให้เรามีความสุขบ้างอยากเห็นแล้วค่ะูชิ
โอ้โหเราก็เริ่มดูจากห้องพักก่อนอันนี้
น่าจะเป็นห้องพักที่มีหน้าต่างมีประตู
เป็นกระจกอย่างงี้นะอยู่ข้างบนนะไม่ได้
อยู่ชั้นลราคาราคาห้องพักที่มีหน้าต่าง
แบบนี้ก็จะมีราคาสูงกว่าสูงขึ้นแต่ก็มี
หลายๆขนาดนะก็ลักษณะขายเหมือนๆโรงแรมนะ
อันนี้แกนสูตนะ
อเหมือนนอนในโรงแรมนะคะ
อืราคาก็ราคาห้องก็ตามแต่ที่เราเลือกคือ
ห้องในเรือต้องเข้าใจก่อนว่าห้องในในเรือ
เนี่ยพื้นที่มันจำกัดเพราะเรือเนี่ยมันมี
พื้นที่จำกัดใช่มั้ยมันก็จะทำห้องแบบใหญ่
แบบโรงแรมเนี่ยไม่ใช่นะคะอย่างอันนี้
เนี่ยก็จะมีระเบียงเห็นมั้ยคะอืมีระเบียง
อยู่อยู่ในห้องนี้ด้วยนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
ประเภทห้องที่เป็นอีกประเภทนึงใช่่มั้ยมี
แบบ 2 ชั้นอ่านะราคาก็จะไม่เหมือนกันใช่
มั้ยค่ะนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นระเบียงห้อง
เวลาที่คุณไปพักเนี่ยอาจจะมานั่งเล่นตรง
นี้นะอืนะอันนี้ก็เป็นของที่อยู่ในห้องนะ
ที่คุณจะใช้นะมีมีเครื่องเป่าผมนะไดเป่า
ผมนะอันนี้ก็เป็นห้องน้ำ
อืห้องน้ำที่อยู่ในเรือนะคะห้องอาบน้ำอื
ก็จะทุกอย่างมีพื้นที่จำกัดไงทุกอย่าง
ต้องเราจะแบบใช้พื้นที่ที่แบบ
เอ่อประหยัดพื้นที่นะคะสามารถแบบใช้
ประโยชน์ได้ทีนี้เวลาเราไปลงเรือวันแรก
ที่เราไปเที่ยวเนี่ยเขาจะมีการต้อนรับอาจ
จะมี Welcome ิอาจจะมีการแสดงต้อนรับนะมี
โชว์เล็กๆนะฮะอันนี้ก็เป็นส่วนกลางของ
เรือนะอ่าก็คือทุกคนที่ไปนั่งเรือสำราญก็
คือออกมาดูได้มาชมการแสดงอาจจะมีมินิ
คอนเสิร์ตมินิ
คอกเทลใช่ค่ะสำหรับต้อนรับนักท่องเที่ยว
นะคะนักท่องเที่ยวก็จะมาแล้วก็เหมือนกับ
จัดปาร์ตี้เล็กๆนะคะเรือที่มีหลายๆชั้นก็
ต้องมีลิฟต์นะมีลิฟขึ้นลงด้วยอันนี้คือ
ลิฟเหรอคะใช่ๆค่ะก็ไม่ได้ลิฟตใหญ่มากใช่
มั้ยมันเป็นเอ่อการจำกัดของพื้นที่อ่ะูบี
อืนะก็สำหรับอ่าเรือที่อาจจะมี 20 ชั้น
ใช่มั้ก็ต้องขึ้นลิฟต์นะคะอันนี้เปาร์ตี้
ใช่มั้ยคะเนี่ยใช่ค่ะอันนี้เขาคก็จัด
ปาร์ตี้ต้อนรับกันนะคะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็จะ
มีเจ้าหน้าที่พาเราไปเดินชมเรือค่ะเราจะ
ได้รู้ว่ามีส่วนบริการตรงไหนบ้างตรงไหน
ที่เราไปใช้บริการฟรีถ้าเราไปสั่งเครื่อง
ดื่มอาหารที่นอกนอกเหนือจากเมนูที่เรือ
จัดให้เราก็ต้องจ่ายเงินอย่างเงี้ยก็จะมี
อ่าสมมติว่าเราซื้อซื้อแพ็คเกจใช่มย
1,999 บาทแต่ถ้าเราไปกินอาหารที่ไม่ได้
อยู่ในแพ็คเกจที่เราซื้อเราก็ต้องจ่าย
เงินเพิ่มอืใช่ค่ะหรือเราไปในสถานที่บาง
ที่เนี่ยเขามีอะไรนะเครื่องดื่มที่เป็น
แอลกอฮอล์อืเราก็ต้องเสียเงินเพิ่มเองแต่
ถ้าเป็นน้ำดื่มโอเคฟรีทุกที่อืน้ำเปล่านะ
แต่ถ้าเป็นเครื่องดื่มที่มีแอลกอฮอล์
เครื่องดื่มอะไรต่างๆที่เราสั่งพิเศษอัน
นี้ต้องจ่ายเงินเพิ่มอืเป็นออเดอร์นะอออเ
เหมือนเราอยากเราอยากดื่มเราก็สั่งแล้วก็
จ่ายเงินเพิ่มเอาเองใช่ค่ะเค้าจะพาเรา
เนี่ยชมเรือค่ะเดินไปทุกส่วนต่างๆแล้วก็
แนะนำบริเวณทางซ้ายมือนะคะจะเป็นเอ่อ
เหมือนๆพิพิธภัณฑ์เอาสินค้าต่างๆมาตั้ง
โชว์ให้ถัดไปก็จะเป็นเอ่อแหล่งช้อปปิ้งนะ
คะขวามือก็จะเป็นห้องที่คุณมาช้อปปิ้งได้
อืใช่มก็จะพาเดินอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
เอ่อบริเวณของบาร์อนะคะอาจจะมีเปโนบามี
การเล่นดนตรีนะคะสเครื่องดื่มได้นอกเหนือ
จากนั้นนะอ๋ออยากมานั่งฟังเพลงบางคนอาจจะ
มีเปียโนมีกีตาร์ใช่มยแล้วก็สั่งเครื่อง
ดื่มแล้วก็นั่งนั่งดูออใช่หรืออาจจะไปที่
coffee  shop นะคะอทีนี้อาหารค่ะอเค้าก็
จะมีห้องอาหารสำหรับนักท่องเที่ยวที่ไป
เที่ยวนะก็จะมีเอ่อการจัดอาหารให้ทุกวัน
วันละกี่มื้อนะคะมากๆก็จะวันนึง 5 มื้อนะ
มื้อเช้ามื้อกลางวันมื้อเบรคมื้อเย็นแล้ว
ก็เป็นมื้อดึกอืเป็นซัฟเฟอร์มืดดึกนะคะ
อาหารก็จะเป็นแบบครัวจีนครัวไทยครัวฝรั่ง
อะไรแบบเนี้ยอืมนะไม่ต้องกังวลนะคะอาหาร
ก็จะมีหลายๆแบบนะคะมีของหวานของหวานเคก
กาแฟเหมือนโรงแรมค่ะอืนะ
มีร้านอาหารนอกเหนือจากที่สมมุติว่าเราไป
แล้วเราอยากจะกินอาหารญี่ปุ่นไม่มีครัว
ญี่ปุ่นไงมีอยากกินอาหารญี่ปุ่นก็ไปร้าน
อาหารที่เค้ามันมีร้านอาหารอื่นๆด้วยนะคะ
นอกเหนือจากที่โรงแรมจัดนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
เอ่อห้องอาหารก็มีหลายๆห้องค่ะอืนะหลายๆ
ห้องให้เราเนี่ยไปเลือกใช้บริการได้นะก็
จะเป็นอาหารแต่ละที่นะเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์คุณก็
ก็ถ้าพูดง่ายๆเนาะูชิอื้อหือก็คือเรามอง
อ่าเรือสำราญเนี่ยเหมือนโรงแรม 1 โรงแรม
ใช่มั้ยเหมือนคุณไปนอนโรงแรมที่เชียงใหม่
ไปนอนโรงแรมที่ภูเก็ตตื่นขึ้นมาก็รับ
ประทานกินอาหารเช้าใช่มั้ยคะใช่ก็จะมี
เหมือนเป็นบุฟเฟ่ต์อ่ามีร้านอาหาร
อืใช่ค่ะอ่าแล้วอาหารเราก็ตักที่เราชอบ
ใช่มั้ยแล้วเค้าก็จะมีแบบเหมือนกับโต๊ะนะ
บริเวณด้านนอกเนี่ยเราก็ไปเลือกนั่งอืชอบ
มุมไหนก็ไปนั่งทานอาหารกันคุยกันจะอยู่
นานเท่าไหร่ก็ไม่ได้จนกว่าครัวจะผิดอืนะ
ห้องอาหารปิดเา้าก็จะมีเปิดเป็นเวลาแล้ว
ก็ปิดเป็นเวลาเพื่อที่จะทำความสะอาด
เคลียร์แล้วก็จับจัดเอ่อมื้อต่อไปนะด
เตรียมมื้อต่อไปให้กับเราในห้องอาหารอื
นอกจากนั้นแล้วส่วน
บริการก็จะมีสัตว์น้ำที่ครูบีเห็นน่ะ
โอ้โหอืสวยนะคะโออันนี้คือใครจะมาว่ายน้ำ
ว่ายน้ำเล่นที่สระน้ำนะก็ตามสบายใช่มั้ย
คะอืเรือบางลำเนี่ยมีสระน้ำเป็นแบบ 7
แห่งบนเรือนะมีมีเยอะหลายที่แล้วก็มีหลาย
แบบข้างบนนี่ก็จะเป็นแบบเหมือนกับมี
เครื่องเล่นแบบเด็กๆนะเป็นสไลเดอร์เด็กๆ
ก็ชอบมากค่ะอืมเหมือนเหมือนเป็นสวนสนุกนะ
เล่นน้ำแล้วก็ไปสไลเดอร์ลงมานะคะใช่ค่ะ
หรือผู้ใหญ่ก็จะชอบเอ่อว่ายน้ำหรือไม่ก็
อาจจะไปสระจากุซี่โอ้โหมีมันมีหลายๆสระ
สระว่ายน้ำคือก็จะมีหลายๆระดับ beginner
intermediate  Advance นะ
คะเหมือนเรียนภาษาไทยนะคะอันนี้ปะว่ายน้ำ
ทีู่ชิให้ดูตอนนี้น่าจะ V  VIP มากนะคะอื
มันก็จะมีสระที่เราสามารถลงไปแช่ตัวนวด
ตัวมีการพ่นไอร้อนอะไรแบบเนี้ยเป็น
จากุซี่ให้เราแบบได้นั่งพักผ่อนสบายๆนะคะ
สำหรับคนที่ไม่ชอบความร้อนแบบคนไทยเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบกลางแดดค่ะไม่เหมือนชาวต่างชาตินะ
คะก็มีสระน้ำในร่มค่ะอือยู่ด้านในอาคาร
ไม่มีแสงแดดอันนี้คนไทยชอบแบบนี้อืมเห็นม
คนไทยไม่ชอบแสงแดดนะคะก็จะสำหรับคนไทยคน
เอเชียเนาะเออตัว
ดำกลัวผิวดำเต้องพาโลชั่น SPF
50 แล้วก็แน่นอนค่ะก็ต้องมีฟิตเนสสำหรับ
คนที่ชอบออกกำลังกาย
อือนะหรือใครจะชอบวิ่งในเครื่องวิ่งก็ได้
นะอันนี้ออกกำลังกายอันนี้สำคัญเลยเนาะ
เพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยต้องออกกำลังกายทุกวัน
นะคะใช่มีฟิตเนสให้ในเรือมีคนที่อตอนเช้า
ตื่นมาอยากจะเต้นแอโรบิ
อืมโอเออนะสนุกสนานมีผู้นำ
แอโรบิกูบีนึกว่าเขาจะใส่เสื้อไปเล่นน้ำ
สงกรานต์นะสงคุชิว่าหลังจากอราบิกเสร็จ
เนี่ยก็ไปแช่ตัวที่จากุซี่ได้เลยเออคนคน
นี้ก็คือใส่ชุดว่ายน้ำสำหรับจะไปแช่
จากุซี่ว่ายน้ำที่สระว่ายน้ำอีกคนนึงก็
เตรียมตัวไปช้อปปิ้งนะมีกระเป๋าด้วยนะ
เต้นอาราบิกเสร็จ
เออหรือคนที่ชอบกีฬาค่ะมีสนามบาสจริงเหรอ
ค่ะใช่ค่ะอันนี้เค้าก็กันไว้ไงชูตไปชูตมา
เดี๋ยวตกลูกบาสหายไปในทะเลหมดตกทเ
อ๋อคือสามารถแบบเล่นกีฬาได้เล่นบาสเกตบอล
ได้ออบางที่มีแบบเป็นฟุตซอลนะคะเป็นสนาม
ฟุตซอลเล็กๆก็นัดกันแล้วก็ไปเตะบอลอะไร
ได้มีหลายๆสนามกีฬานะให้เล่นบางที่ก็มี
สนามเทนนิสด้วยเรือบางลำก็มีสำหรับกีฬานะ
สำหรับคนที่พาลูกๆไปค่ะูบีอออันนี้สำหรับ
เด็กๆเหรอคะทำอะไรคะเนี่ยก็เรือลำไหน
เนี่ยค่ะที่ที่แบบว่าเรามีเด็กๆใช่มั้ย
เรามีเด็กๆไปแล้วอยากจะอยากจะเอ่อออก
กำลังกายนะคะเขาคก็มีจัดกิจกรรมเป็น
กิจกรรมอาร์ตเป็นกิจกรรมที่ให้เด็กๆเล่น
เกมวิ่งไล่จับกันอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะก็จะมี
ห้องสำหรับเด็กบางทีก็มาเล่านิทานค่ะแล้ว
อันนี้ก็จะเป็นห้องเกมค่ะสำหรับคนที่ชอบ
เล่นเกม
โอโหเรือสำราญจริงๆค่ะครูชิมีห้องเล่นเกม
ด้วยใช่ค่ะมีห้องคาสิโน
โอสำหรับเกมของผู้
ใหญ่มีเกมเด็กๆแล้วก็มีเกมแบบผู้ใหญ่นะคะ
อ่าใช่ค่ะเออคนก็ชอบเล่นเหมือนกันนะ
คาสิโนนะ
คะแล้วก็เวลาเหนื่อยนะก็จะมาฟักเอ่อพัก
ที่ coffee  shop สั่งเครื่องดื่มอะไรืม
ดื่มกาแฟนะคะดื่มชานะคะหรือจะไปดิสโกเทค
อ่าอืมไปเต้นๆ้กันนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นส่วน
บริการนะ coffee  shop อาจจะมีหลายแห่งนะ
ไปสั่งกินกาแฟหรืออะไรอันนี้จะเป็นพวกกับ
คอกเทลเล้าที่แบบมีโชว์ค่ะมีการแสดงโชว์
ทุกวันทุกคืนอืมากๆจะมีตอนกลางคืนตอนเย็น
ค่ะใครอยากดูก็มาที่ห้องนี้นะคะอแต่ละที่
ก็จะมีอาจจะมีโชว์ตลกโชว์โชว์มีอาจจะมี
คอนเสิร์ตเล็กๆนะคะแล้วแต่โชว์ในแต่ละวัน
ก็มีไม่เหมือนกันนะนะและอันนี้ก็เป็นห้อง
ที่แบบคนอยากจะช้อปปิ้งค่ะเครื่องเพชร
นาฬิกาหรูอือืนะนาฬิกาเนี่ยก็อาจจะ 199
บาทไม่
มีนาฬิกาหรูมันต้องโลเหล็กอ้าอราคาแล้วก็
แน่นอนค่ะสำหรับคนที่ชอบนวดอืมอันนี้คิด
ว่า
90% นะหลายๆคนก็จะชอบนวดแน่นอนเนาะอาจจะ
นวดสปานะอ่านี่เลยโรร่าเปีเนี่ยนะคะใช่
หรืออาจจะมีห้องแล้วก็มีห้องซาวหน้าอื
ห้องที่แบบเข้าไปแล้วต้องไปเติมให้ร้อนอ
นะมีห้องนวดห้องอบเอ่อซาวน่าห้องเอ่อห้อง
สปาออันนี้ก็จะเป็นเรื่องของเกี่ยวกับ
อาหารในแต่ละที่นะอนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นอัน
นี้เป็นเอ่อทิปของเอ่อเส้นทางไปอเมริกานะ
เป็นแบบทะเลคาริบเบียนนะไปเม็กซิโกนะราคา
98,000  900 ไม่มี 99 นะอืนะไปกับเรือลำ
นี้ลำนี้ก็เป็นเรือที่โอ้โหสำราญทุกส่วน
เลยนะอันเนี้ยมีทั้งหมด 20 ชั้นครูบีอื
อืมเป็นือ 20 ชั้นมีสระว่ายน้ำมีสวนสนุก
มีดิสโกเทคแบบอสวยเนาะตึกสูงมีสไลเดอร์อื
ใช่มีสไลเดอร์น้ำเนี่ย 6 ที่มีสาว่ายน้ำ 7
ที่อยู่ในนี้อืมนะมีส่วนบริการต่างๆดูจาก
ข้างบนเนี่ยโอ้โหสีสันสวยงามอืใช่ค่ะอัน
นี้ก็เป็นทริปกับท่องเที่ยวนะคะอันเนี้ย
มีตั้งแต่เดือนมกราคมจนถึงธันวาคมเลยนะ
อืม 7  7 คืนค่ะก็สบายเลยนะถ้าเราสนใจที่
จะนั่งเรือสำราญแล้วก็ไปเที่ยวใช่มั้ยคะ
เราก็เข้าไปเช็คใน Google ในเว็บไซต์นะคะ
ก็จะมีราคาเลยเนาะอย่างครูชิเอามานี่ก็
เป็นตัวอย่างนะคะว่าเ่อเป็นเรือสำราญที่
ไปเที่ยวในแถบเอเชียไปสิงคโปร์มาเลเซีย
หรือว่าไปยุโรปไปอเมริกานะก็จะราคาแตก
ต่างแต่ก็ดูแล้วเนี่ยราคาโปรโมชั่นนะูชิ
ใช่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยช่วงเดือนกุมภาพันธ์
เนี่ยมันจะมีช่วงของตรุษจีนชนิ New  Year
นะช่วงวันวาเลนไทนอืนะเป็นเดือนแห่งความ
รักเรือสำราญมาประเทศไทยหลายลำมี 6 ลำ
มั้งแล้วก็ก็จะมีสิ่งที่ให้คุณเลือกไงคุณ
จะนั่งเรืออย่างเดียวตลอดทิศการเดินทาง
ไม่ว่าเรือจะไปที่ไหนก็ไปจนวนกลับมาที่
เดิมนะก็นั่งเรืออย่างเดียวหรือจะนั่ง
เรือแล้วก็ไปต่อเครื่องบินกลับอืนะอย่าง
เช่นนั่งเรือจากท่าเรือเอ่อแหลมฉบัง
ประเทศไทยแล้วก็ล่องไปเที่ยวอะไรอ่ะ
สิงคโปร์นะปีนพอปีนังเสร็จอาจจะบินกลับมา
กรุงเทพฯเลยเห็นมก็แล้วแต่ที่เราจะซื้อไป
นะคะมันก็จะมีมีให้เราเลือกหมดนะค่ะคือใน
เว็บไซต์นะคะในเว็บไซต์จะจะมีให้เราเลือก
ว่าจะนั่งเครื่องบินแล้วไปนั่งเรือหรือ
นั่งเรือแล้วกลับมาโดยเครื่องบินคือเราไป
เลือกได้เลยนะคะแล้วก็จะไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
เนาะวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะก็ขอบคุณครู
ชิมากๆเลยอยากไปจังเลยค่ะอยากไปเอ่อร้อง
คาราโอเกะนะว่ายน้ำที่เรือสำราญนะูชิเรา
จะไปเที่ยวเรือสำราญกันนะคะอืเเรือกำลัง
มารอนะครูมีอ้าเลือกโปรแกรมไว้ค่ะเลือก
โปรแกรมไว้ได้ค่ะเงินที่เก็บไว้คิดว่า
หมดต้องทำงานแล้วก็เก็บเงินเก็บเงินก่อน
นะคะถึงจะไปเที่ยวเรือสำราญได้นะคะไม่
เป็นไรเที่ยวไปเดี๋ยวเก็บใหม่
เดี๋ยวค่อยเก็บใหม่โอเคเนาะงั้นเอาไว้พบ
กันใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปนะเราก็จะมาคุยแล้วก็
เอาเรื่องราวมาคุยให้นักเรียนฟังอีกนะคะ
ได้ค่ะครูบีก็วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วก็ลานัก
เรียนไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ